prémarque donc nous voici dans le magasin de jouets
c'est l'un des ensembles les plus incroyables
que j'aie jamais vus ce que j'aime à propos de cet
endroit c'est un grand contraste avec Cuba
c'est beaucoup de voitures technologiquement avancées
quand vous avez une nouvelle Bentley la
McLaren est la  Maseratis la
mercedes-benz les jaguars et bien sûr l'
un des véhicules d'assaut les plus avancés technologiquement
sur la planète Terre à un
endroit, cela vous donne l'impression d'être à
un autre moment la seule chose qui
vous ramène en quelque sorte, ce qui est l'un de mes
préférés  les voitures c'est la Corvette c'est qu'un
bateau de course on a l'impression d'être dans le
futur ici dans un magasin de jouets et j'adore ça
je le laisse utiliser mon garage aujourd'hui pour
filmer ce n'est pas grave